so here's goldman sachs
when you think about goldman sachs you
only think about one state you think
about one city new york new york city
you know you don't think about anything
else it's
new york goldman sachs right new york
goldman sachs and elliott management
corp are breathing new life into the
decade old idea of converting the miami
to west palm beach corridor into a
southern hub for finance and investing a
notion that would have
monumental implications for the area's
development
now goldman is weighing a new florida
for its asset management on while
billionaire paul singer's 41 billion
dollar hedge fund
elliot management court plans to move
its headquarters to west palm beach
according to
people familiar with discussions
trailblazing's blazing moves by industry
giants could open the floodgates of
other firms
many of which have been hesitant to
leave the center of finance
financial universe for the promise of
better can you imagine if these guys
make them look
carl icahn recently decided to relocate
his asset management from
to florida ken griffin citadel plans to
open an office in miami mexico according
to
a person with knowledge of his plans you
know elon musk just told a few friends
that he's leaving california for texas
elon musk is telling his friends
in an interview a few months ago he said
no i'm not leaving california just
recently his friends
imagine you're having dinner with your
friends saying ilan are you ever going
to leave california i'm thinking about
moving to texas
and friends are saying man you know
elon's thinking about moving to texas
they're thinking there is no
consequences but people are going to be
leaving
what happens if a goldman leaves to
florida it's we talk about this every
week we're shocked that a company is
moving and then it's every week there's
a new one
and it's a bigger one and it's a higher
profile one
these government leaders in sacramento
california and is albany the capital of
new york is it albany
they must be so myopic and so stupid
and not have enough people around them
to challenge them on anything
this is a crisis of epic proportions for
these states
it's as big as the pandemic if you ask
me when you have
companies leave because the pandemic is
eventually going to end right they're
going to have a vaccine things
eventually will slow down and get back
to normal
you have these companies bolting i mean
multiply this tax revenue year by year
by year
and then you have these high earners
that aren't paying individual income tax
into the state and why wouldn't they all
move to texas and florida there's no
state income tax
i mean i cannot believe that they aren't
treating this like the crisis that it is
because
it is only the beginning i think cuomo
is thinking behind closed doors what do
you think he's he offers i think he's
thinking about his book
i think about the next interview he's
doing i think that yes i do i'm
almost very aware of this he begged and
pleaded look i'll cook you dinner
remember that quote
i remember that look come over i'll cook
you dinner don't leave
uh cuomo's aware of this i don't think
he's immune to this but
at the same time you know this says this
decades-old
um breathing new life into this
decades-old idea this is not a new idea
of new yorkers basically thinking about
coming down to mike but now they're
actually doing it
relax i got you tom i'm fired up
this is this is nothing new i feel like
they've been playing hopscotch for a
while look born and raised in miami i've
lived in my entire life
i know a lot of people that basically i
mean half my friends have been like
yeah man i just couldn't do it in new
york especially when they have kids
especially when they have kids you can
be single and have a time of your
freaking life in new york city run
around
you meet a girl you meet a guy next
thing you know you have kids you're
thinking i'm living in a freaking shoe
box i'm paying five thousand dollars a
month here what the [ __ ] am i doing
hold on for five grand a month i can get
a sick house on the water in boca raton
or in west palm or in miami in fort
lauderdale whatever
and i feel like for years for decades
people have been sort of playing
hopscotch with
you know what's that what's the jump
rope game when you you know you're kind
of like
thinking about going thinking about
going next thing double dutch thank you
who was that
um eric you're thinking about doing
double dutch
boom pandemic happens and then they're
thinking dude i've been thinking about
this for years now
i'm talking about just individuals
forget about corporations we can we can
talk about corporations as well
they've been thinking about it forever
now and now the pandemic happens they're
like screw it
what do we have to [ __ ] lose so
here's a question here's a question down
what keeps i get what keeps people in
california i totally get it i mean if
you've been there we went there the
weather we're hanging out with shauna
listen the weather i lived there 20
some years beautiful what what keeps
people in new york
well look number one there's still it's
talking about individuals or
corporations what keeps people in new
york it is the financial corporations
okay talent talent yeah like i live in
miami you cannot compare the brain power
and the talent in new york versus miami
miami's got a lot of favorable things
going this way
clearly the weather the weather the
weather the weather the low taxes
the fun the sun all that you you'll be
very hard-pressed to find a very
intellectual conversation going in miami
bro that's not gonna happen
for the most part bro like there's just
not that level of brain trust in miami
it's changing though it's changing um
what else is keeping people in new york
i mean look no doubt
and and jerry seinfeld did did a thing
about this
where he's like look you could you could
say that new york is
you know dying and nobody's coming back
to new york new york is still the best
city in the country in my opinion
straight up as far as like but what why
dude
i mean was the last time you just hung
out don't get me wrong listen i love you
i'm not i i love but i'm asking you why
my favorite thing to do in this world
and you're talking about somebody who's
born and raised in miami loves miami if
there's one place i could live
year round it'd be miami because i just
can't take the sure
but my favorite thing to do is just put
on some earbuds and just
walk around new york so here's a
question or to live
for a vacation okay so but i'm saying
why do people live
and stay in that's your question because
12 years out of the year 12 months
i say you have we have some it's culture
that's what i was going to say i was
going to say culture culture and then
everybody the belief that you are in the
epicenter of the world i mean new york
is where everything happens or at least
it used to be so i think
that kept people there feel of feeling
of missing out you know
professionally if you live somewhere
else it's just not the same or it hasn't
been i mean
the buzz and the excitement of new york
i think if you look if you look at
the the look at cuomo's attitude look at
trump's attitude
look at new york's attitude right
there's an attitude about new york it's
very attractive the attitude of new york
it's like
no here's what i'm going to do and we're
going to figure out a way you don't like
you know it's like
it's you can make it there you can make
it anyway very
you know unique attitude about that
attitude does not exist in miami i'm
telling
but that what i'm trying to tell you is
i've done business with people from
every state
i've done business with people from
every state every religion pretty much
you can think i've done business with
everybody right
there's something very unique about
doing business with people from new york
i love doing business with people from
new york
the way they are you're going to know
very quickly if
something's going to happen or not it's
not like well can i get you something
would you like to see
hey mary can you get us something that's
like so listen you know when i look at
what you got going on and what we got
going on i think there's something here
what do you think how about we do this i
think it's really only the
beggar it's just a very simple open
conversation with them they have but
that talent
is transferable to any market you take
that talent to a market like florida you
got a big upside
oh yeah yeah big upside right and so you
go to florida a state with no taxes
weather year-round yesterday we're
looking at checking out the weather last
night in palm beach
64 degrees it hit 47 yesterday people
are freaking palm beach they're freaking
out
iguanas are dying that's freezing that's
the point yeah iguanas are dying they're
freezing right yeah real story i know
you're telling me this yeah so
but 60 46 in new york is like a huge
we got covered tom's got 46 in new york
so yeah so you know you people people
don't think anyone's gonna leave new
york until they do
yep that's that's really what it says
there's a gallop behind them you know a
couple other things now with all these
people and all these corporations
leaving new york what's gonna have to
happen they're gonna have to raise taxes
for the people that stay there right i
mean isn't that logical that it's gonna
even get worse
yeah adam you know i'm with you man as
far as like hanging out in new york
there's nothing like it
last time i was in new york was in
february and that was right
i would say like a week before the
pandemic and i already noticed it was
different
i really did i think de blasio has done
such damage to that city i mean they
need a mayor like giuliani to come in
there and restore that city
because that was new york in the 70s in
the giuliani of the 90s or giuliani of
today
the 90s the big difference yeah that
guy's a mess right now by the way if
you're watching this you're listening to
this what do you think about it what
keeps people in new york what keeps
people in new york why don't people want
to leave new york i mean obviously
the the slow slow what the pandemic did
it exposed states like california and
new york in a big way
pandemic was not good for california new
york by the way no horrible
horrible for those two states can i make
one last point sure and i really truly
mean this
i believe you look at these two states
by far handling the pandemic the worst
the worst
situation the worst stories we hear are
in california new york
i believe that cuomo thinks he's a rock
star i really do
the interviews the books i think he's
thinking of what's going on
for him i i truly believe he's thinking
more about what's next
and i think the same thing about newsome
i don't think they care enough about
what's going on
they're thinking about their next move
newsome's thinking about being president
cuomo's thinking about being a rock star
and whatever else is coming up after and
they're neglecting things that are
happening right now because they're so
selfish
who do you think will be president first
who has a higher likelihood of being
president
cuomo or nusselt newsome i go cuomo tell
me why
uh i think he's got a broader appeal i
think
look you think that uh cuomo's hand uh
new york's handling the pandemic worse i
think
i think between garcetti and and
newsom they're freaking disaster new
york
in essence this is where the pandemic
started all right so thinking about
people are living within like
shoe boxes of each other like that's a
lot harder to deal with people are
living on living on living on people
right on top of people
versus l.a is completely spread out like
you can
eat outdoor no problem weather's fine
you can
deal with this new york it's freezing
you're living on top of each other
totally different beast totally
different beast and
so you're saying cuomo before news i'm
just saying do you think america is
ready for a single president
is he not married he's not married
what's going on there
you can read into it i'm not going to
talk about it i don't think he's got the
lindsey graham thing going on
do you is that's common knowledge what's
up with lindsay lindsey graham thing
oh you know put it this way i wouldn't
be shocked if lindsey graham was one of
those 25 guys hanging out in a hungarian
origin
you think so oh yeah you think he
parties in hungary
so go back to it so do you think america
is ready for a single president
look do you think america let me tell
you i'm being i'm back by the way look
but listen i mean the things that are
going on in america right now
ready for a crappy president so yeah a
single one will be fine foreign that's
crazy i agree with you tom
so so so wait a minute i'm actually
asking a serious question when john
kennedy was running everybody said is
america ready for a catholic president
and the answer was what yes is america
ready for
a barack obama yes is america ready for
a woman to be a president is america
ready for a single man to be a president
yeah well
as far as a single man let me tell you
something the guy's going to have no
shortage of
ladies being like look you know i see
you're saying that's not what i'm asking
you i'm asking you does america care
do you care if your president is single
or not america doesn't give you care do
you care care less
do you care do you care no you don't
don't i literally be competent
clearly you care no no i'm asking
clearly you care i tell you it's not
about me
there's eight men in here not one we
also
no we all said no but what about you you
think you're going somewhere where
you're saying i know you're going
you think late you think women are going
to be saying 100 yes i don't know about
that
i don't it's going to be like i don't
know i think you know how can you relate
to me if you don't have a family
he's never been married he's been
married okay what are we talking about
then he's got kids he's not married
today
wow gives a [ __ ] they're smart then he
he picks up so what you're saying is you
don't give a sh
if you're watching this by the way i'm
asking you this if you really don't care
if the president is single put thumbs up
if you care for the president to be
married
put thumbs down they've all acted like
they were single anyway yeah everybody
i got my friend vince you know vince he
just i got a random text from he said
lindsey graham definitely putts from the
rough that's for sure shout out to vince
richardson that's my guy
how would vince know though vince's got
some inroads he knows what's going on
maybe he's hosted the parties
vince is in touch with the people he
knows is in touch with the people but
i don't think bottom line is i don't
think anyone cares well look the reason
why i'm bringing
this up i'm bringing this up because
bloomberg is single
and he ran and nobody brought it up and
it wasn't a topic
it wasn't like something hey you know is
anybody
you know going to bring that up and it
was never brought up no well quite
frankly bloomberg man on the debate
stage he was
god he was a putt he had charisma he had
swag
maybe he was style you could tell he had
all sorts of energy yeah you agree with
me right
bloomberg he had what trump damn good by
the way that that comment right there
could be used if he was running today
they would use that